the Joe Rogan experience you tell a lot
about a man whether or not he's one of
those dudes that has one in wallet phone
cases Rashad Evans you're a wallet phone
case guy you pack it all into one
package you know what I wasn't always a
wallet phone case guy that's kind of
something that just you know I kind of
evolved into I was the one that was
carrying around the man purse the man
purse were well and and after a while I
kind of transitioned to just the though
the wallet case that's a lot of work
they look how thick that sucker is it's
like a Costanza look at that I know in
their thinking giant every single time I
clean it out I tell myself I'm not gonna
put any more cards in there except for
the ones I need but it just attracts the
card yeah that's a problem I have one of
those Ridge wallets you know what those
are
yeah those are the [ __ ] because you
can't really get much in there I get
like a credit card or two and my license
exactly that's what I need I need to
have that yeah there's nothing else to
carry but what I have to and it's got a
little money clip on it so I'll shove a
couple bills in there and that's it
that's it I go out like that that's what
I need that's what you need front pocket
huh all this nonsense that's so thick
it's thick you might as well go back to
the man purse but you know what I might
as well get a backpack one of these I
just sent two too steep a Miocic
those look alright though but it dope
right yeah it's my own company makes
well we don't make them we buy them from
brutes and we put our stamp on it yeah
leather right you might want to go in
for you yeah yeah you're a bold man you
can wear a fanny pack ya know I was
rocking I was rocking the man purse
before anybody else is wearing it right
now out in America out of Europe they
were doing a long time ago but yeah
America I was like one of the other
Trailblazers I like to say liesl among
my friends it is a weird thing right
like guys are not supposed to wear bags
but women have like my [ __ ] all these
different brands of bags they carry
around Fendi and Gucci in this and man
makes you look like you're special
because you got some fancy bag and
carrying a bag actually helped me be
more prepared than ever because I mean I
would always be can't one of them stools
can't carry enough stuff and I always
would come things wishing I had things
that I didn't have and I'm like you know
what
the bag work but why is it that we're
afraid to carry a bag a good guy can
carry a backpack backpacks fine I guess
you got a got [ __ ] to do you got a
backpack you [ __ ] serious
alright it's got two straps yeah one
strap like man what's wrong with you I
think it's because you had to to do that
the the feminine hold at times with the
ones the one strap yeah Nichkhun
but dudes do all that shoulder so you
don't have to do that then you're like
it's cuz it's a Salinas man then it's
manly then it's very strange right how a
bag became manly or not manly based on
the amount of straps to sit in line yeah
and then for women it's like it's like a
status symbol
nobody gives a [ __ ] what kind of
backpack you have right feet if a dude
has a nice backpack no one's like bro
yeah I mean you got a nice fannypack
fannypack sort of not really it doesn't
get the respect it deserves
Fanny sticks out the people like okay
he's got enough balls to carry fanny
pack yes there's a little bit of that a
little bit of that you know a little bit
I don't give a [ __ ]
I seen a fanny pack carried where it's
across the shoulder that looks concrete
but weak people like with their cowards
cowards do fashion cowards they don't
want anybody calling them out I'm
wearing a fanny pack so another Nunes is
shoulder bag it's not a shoulder bag
[ __ ] where it's a fat man's fanny pack
we're in it away you're not supposed to
wear it it's like if you wore a backpack
around your waist like people would be
like what the [ __ ] are you doing it's
not a backpack when it's around its
wrapped around your waist what do you
what I mean you'd think that Karen did
here you have everything you want like
right yeah I guess I'm just trying to I
guess John is just where it's like say
it how I think I would wear that one one
you got you kind of convincing me Joe
that maybe the front the front carry
might be there it's the way to go we
only issue as girls won't [ __ ] you some
girls some girls like you wear a fanny
pack you up that's it see I'm married
anyways I'm good perfect yeah I'm good
every married man like myself that man
should have a [ __ ] fanny pack
deterrent push parents it's a little bit
of that but it's also [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] right there keep my [ __ ] right
there
hilarious yeah keep it together
[Applause]